d'accord on évite les sujets qui fâchent
c'est noël et pour une fois qu'on a tout
le monde à la maison et tout le monde
sait bien c'est le problème en plus
margerie a dit qu'elle voulait nous
présenter quelqu'un si elle nous ramène
le même genre d'énergumène que ses
soeurs on n'est pas dans la panade et le
monde tu présentes unique
bonjour un autre enfin trois groupes à
lui donner des idées toi laissera la
karl lagerfeld
il sera lâchera qui passera la grh 1 ça
arrive en carriole quoi et s'ils font
des bonnes sur les mains je fais quoi eh
bah tu rigoles du fait que je vienne
on a gardé ticket si vous voulez les
changer en même temps vous voulez pas
savoir que vous étiez un grand oui voilà
hamels à main et maintenant alors qu
pour vos parents c'est la désolation de
ce mouvement je peux toucher vous aurez
encore assez s'était pas rendu ccq mois
en tout cas ils vont nous faire une
jolie confrérie c'est ce qu'ils disent
quoi